so obviously that's a collaboration with
you and bts how did that happen how did
those spheres collide it was like a
classic sort of social media rumor that
i don't know if it was true or not but i
got told or bts asked if you'd like to
do a song for them
and i was like well that's never gonna
work it's that's like
you know the movie twins with arnold
schwarzenegger
danny devito but but then the idea just
sat in my head for a while and then
the title came through and then this
song just appeared out of nowhere one
day and i felt like oh this this might
be the one and it's a because it's a
love song about difficult love or love
that requires overcoming some boundaries
and so we thought well this would really
fit with the two of us yeah sort of
weird way and did you go to korea yes i
went to korea yeah well to be fair i
didn't see any other koreans except bts
really and loads of people in hazmat
suits it was really intense wow yeah we
we got permission from the government to
go for two days
and half of that was in like a holding
cell
and then i was taken to a room and then
bts came in we had the best time and
then i was basically told to [ __ ] off
thanks
not by bts but
charming
so fun doing this whole thing with them
yeah
[Music]